[Musik]
fußballer mario götze und seine frau ann
kathrin sind zum ersten mal eltern
geworden
nur zwei tage nach marius 28 geburtstag
ist der kleinen rom zur welt gekommen
die beiden sind übrigens nicht die
einzigen die ihr kind einen
außergewöhnlichen namen geben
sehr beliebt bei promis orte so nannte
der king of pop michael jackson seine
tochter nach der französischen
hauptstadt paris und die beckhams ihren
sohn nach einem stadtteil new york
brooklyn kim kardashian und kanye west
sätzen gegen auf himmelsrichtungen ihre
erste tochter heißt maus lässt auch obst
und tiere sind in der kinder promi welt
vertreten
coldplay-sänger chris martin tochter
wurde apple genannt sarah connors
tochter hört auf den namen delpy am
verrücktesten wird es bei space extrem
vielen macht der name ist so schwer
auszusprechen dass wir ihn an dieser
stelle einfach nur einblenden von spacex
kommen wir zum nächsten
riesenunternehmen amazon gründer jeff
bezos hat bei instagram einer an ihn
gerichtete hass mails veröffentlicht
in der e-mail beleidigt ein kunde namens
dave besseres aufs übelste und äußert
rassistisches gedankengut weil amazon
seine solidarität mit der black leisten
männerbewegung und form eines banners
auf der website und einer 10 millionen
dollar spende trägt bis schreibt das ist
ihm wichtig sei diese art von hass
sichtbar zu machen
außerdem macht er klar und dave du bist
die art von kunde die ich gern verliere
sängerin macht wieder musik und das
obwohl er eigentlich eine große pause
angekündigt hatte nach seiner letzten
tournee teilte at schulen seien fans
über instagram mit dass es zeit sei mal
wieder rauszugehen und mehr von der welt
zu sehen
aufgrund von chur wird 95 konnte der
brite jedoch nicht für reisen und
scheint sich nun wieder der musik zu
widmen
denn der singer songwriter jerry lewis
verriet jetzt der britischen zeitung the
sun dass sie gemeinsam an einigen songs
gearbeitet hätten
wir können es kaum erwarten etwas davon
zu hören musik macht übrigens auch
social media astana cola
die hat ihren ersten eigenen song
herausgebracht der song heißt laut und
ist ein mega ohrwurm in den sozialen
netzwerken wurde er bereits mehrfach
geteilt darunter auch von bekannten
stars wie lüfter gntm teilnehmerin
tamara oder youtube in anna maria damm
und dann erzählt wie sich anfühlt von so
vielen kolleginnen zu porto zu werden
weil für mich wird es halt alles selbst
eine riesen überraschung dass mich so
viele unterstützer haben weil ich habe
die meisten gar nicht erst gefragt also
ich habe nicht nach ich habe ein zwei
drei leute die halt wirklich eng sind
hat okay leute ich habe meinen sorgen
darauf gebracht einpreist info aber die
meisten sind einfach richtig spontan
haben mich unterstützt und das ist für
mich echt unglaublich wirklich es macht
mich unglaublich glücklich weil die
steckt so viel arbeit rein in ein
projekt um die leute tun das
wertschätzen und ja ich finde sowas
richtig toll auch bei wir unterstützen
uns alle eigentlich gegenseitig
untereinander und das finde ich ja das
schönste eigentlich an diesen ganzen
[Musik]